bonjour merci de nous accompagner
pendant cette première demi-heure vous
êtes élu de la haute-savoiement du
groupe Union centriste on va longuement
revenir sur cette intervention
d'Emmanuel Macron vous l'avez entendu
100 jours pour apaiser le pays c'est le
cap qui l'a donné hier soir c'est le bon
cas pour vous
c'est le cap de l'été ce qui me surprend
énormément dans la dans l'intervention
du président de la République hier soir
c'est l'absence de
mesure forte ou de
symboles pour clore cette période en
réalité
on a une forme d'enfilage de perles
un discours assez convenu assez
classique et une perspective qui
a aucun moment ne lui permet de se
remettre en cause lui ou son
gouvernement dans la manière dont ils
ont géré cette réforme des retraites
comme si c'était un mal nécessaire il
faut les passer par là et que c'était
utile le fait de faire un si ce manque
d'introspection ce manque de recul et de
jugement sur ce qui s'est passé
me laisse penser que les 100 jours qui
viennent auront énormément de mal à être
comme il le dit 100 jours d'apaisement
pour le pays et donc c'est là que c'est
là que je suis inquiet parce qu'en fait
les difficultés auxquelles les Français
sont confrontés les inquiétudes sur la
situation internationale les questions
de pouvoir d'achat restent des questions
extrêmement fortes il n'en a finalement
que très peu parlé et donc pas de
changement de méthodologie pas de pas
d'autocritique
en somme est-ce qu'il y a un nu est-ce
qu'il y a une nouvelle étape du mot du
deuxième quinquennat d'Emmanuel Macron
qui s'ouvre j'en doute vraiment et je
suis assez inquiet sur la relation qui
existe entre l'exécutif et le pays et le
Parlement affaibli à son national et le
Sénat malgré c'est sa bonne volonté
auront énormément de mal à jouer ce rôle
là si le président de la République ne
prend pas du recul et ne fait pas
confiance au corps intermédiaire et à la
vie démocratique du pays c'est à dire le
Parlement et les collectivités
territoriales
il a il a continué à la défendre disons
qu'elle était nécessaire mais il a quand
même reconnu qu'elle n'était pas
acceptée c'est un pompon
oui mais comme s'il ne considérait qu'il
n'y avait pas joué de rôle ou que
lui-même et le gouvernement des
Elisabeth borne n'avait pas une
responsabilité dans la manière dont les
choses se sont passées il prend comme
exemple hier soir la question de la
Conférence nationale sur la sur la fin
de vie enfin si c'est ça le mode de
gouvernement des 100 jours qui viennent
à faire des conférences thématiques avec
des citoyens tirés au sort pour faire
pour dire en gros ce que le gouvernement
a envie qu'il est citoyens disent ça
marchera jamais on peut pas tenir le
pays le pays et c'est représentant à
l'écart de de de la décision publique
regardez par exemple sur la question de
l'immigration pas un mot hier soir on
avait un projet de loi qui était inscrit
à l'ordre du jour du Sénat qui a été
retiré qu'est-ce qu'on en fait on n'en
sait rien on va aller vers les grands
des grands événements oui
il faut prendre des mesures d'accord et
alors on va attendre la semaine
prochaine que madame la Première
ministre
l'agenda parlementaire jusqu'au 14
juillet c'est ça le la nouvelle méthode
de gouvernement du président de la
République c'est pour ça que je suis je
suis extrêmement inquiet on va parler
des institutions très bien alors on va
on va il dit qu'avec la présidente de
l'Assemblée nationale le président du
Sénat on va annoncer des des choses à
l'international très bien et on parle
pas du tout de la manière dont le
pouvoir est incarné notamment par un
certain nombre de deux ministres il
parle il parle pas de cette une de
Playboy de de Madame Schiappa qui a été
une erreur
sur le fond mais une erreur sur la forme
qui est considérable donc
il y a pas d'autocrity hier soir je n'ai
pas entendu d'autocritique et ça
m'inquiète beaucoup sur la réforme des
retraites est-ce que maintenant la porte
de sortie c'est le référendum pour vous
jamais
jamais parce que le référendum en France
dans la culture plébiscitaire du
référendum fera en sorte que les
Français ne répondront pas à la question
qu'on leur pose je prends pour exemple
le référendum de 69 qui référendum du
départ du général de Gaulle dedans il y
avait la régionalisation la réforme du
Sénat et et finalement les Français
disent non en général le Gaulle donc il
y a un vrai risque institutionnel à ce
que ce référendum soit une occasion de
dire autre chose que la question ça pose
une autre question
que le Sénat rejette le ce rythme
cette idée là je pense que c'est d'une
très mauvaise idée ça nous emmènerait
d'ailleurs sur un un timing qui n'est
pas le bon moi vous savez moi je me suis
abstenu sur la forme des retraites donc
j'ai beaucoup j'aurais beaucoup de
choses à dire sur cette réforme là sur
le fond et sur la manière dont elle a
été conduite mais le retour devant le
peuple sous forme cette nouvelle forme
du du Rip
ou du Rick c'est ça c'est une mauvaise
idée
il a tendu là-bas au syndicat vous dites
il faut rejoindre avec les syndicats il
aura tendu la main il les invités à
nouveau aujourd'hui à l'Élysée sauf que
le patrona Eva mais les syndicats
refusent d'y aller pour le moment le
robergé il dit il faut un délai de
décence ils ont raison pour vous
complètement ils vont lui poser un lapin
ce matin c'est tout à fait logique
la négation dans ce pays des corps
intermédiaires c'est à dire de ceux qui
représentent quelque chose du lié au
mouvement social au monde associatif au
monde économique c'est
c'est la négation du pays réel et on
peut considérer que le Président de la
République a un problème avec le pays
réel avec le pays profond donc et il y a
une responsabilité à avoir coupé les
ponts avec leur grand berger avec la
CFDT avec cette forme de syndicalisme
social-démocrate constructive qui avait
d'ailleurs soutenu la réforme par point
en 2019
oui c'est une évidence avoir ne pas les
avoir reçus par au moment où il y avait
et une forme de de colère dans le pays
et dire l'apport était toujours ouverte
aujourd'hui c'est une ironie qui est
insupportable pour pour ces
représentants là donc je comprends qu'il
n'aillent pas à la à la Réunion
aujourd'hui et puis les autres sujets ça
va être quoi ça va être par exemple
toutes les mesures que le Sénat a voté
que le Conseil constitutionnel a fait
sauter dont il a pas reparlé hier
ça a été une des raisons pour lesquelles
un certain nombre de sénateurs ont voté
cette réforme ça a été une raison pour
laquelle un certain nombre de député
notamment la République était prêt à la
voter et il faudra qu'on en reparle de
ces sujets là comme il faudra quand même
qu'on reparle un certain nombre de
sujets dans le domaine du pouvoir
d'achat et dans le domaine vous
souhaitez que les mesures retoquées par
le conseil constitent soit dans une loi
travail prochainement oui sauf que la
difficulté c'est que la première
ministre a annoncé qu'elle ne courrait
plus aux 49-3 et qu'il faudra trouver
une nouvelle majorité sur ce sujet là y
compris avec la gauche de la majorité
présidentielle
c'est la question est totalement ouverte
le 49-3 était utilisé pour cette réforme
de retraites est-ce que le gouvernement
est prêt à l'utiliser à nouveau sur des
mesures qui ont été
sorties de ce projet loi de financement
rectificatif la sécurité sociale
Emmanuel Macron a tendu là-bas aux
oppositions et Aubers notamment il veut
relancer une nouvelle coalition on en
parle avec notre journaliste
parlementaire Alex tout ça
[Musique]
bonjour Alex bonjour Ariane bonjour les
carrés bonjour
c'est Manuel Macron a essayé d'apporter
quelques réponses à la crise politique
que nous connaissons ah oui alors même
si le chef de l'État ne parle pas
explicitement de crise démocratique
comme le font ces opposants comme le
font elle est syndicale Emmanuel Macron
a reconnu hier en creux qu'il y avait
une défiance des citoyens vis-à-vis de
nos institutions de la démocratie et
qu'il fallait les faire évoluer ces
institutions écoutez le président de la
République
1 et démocratique signifie également que
nous devons lutter contre le sentiment
persistant que voter ne serait plus
décidé je proposais à cet égard en lien
avec la présidente de l'Assemblée
nationale le président du Sénat le
président du Conseil économique social
et environnemental des grandes pistes
pour que le fonctionnement nos
institutions gagne en efficacité mais
aussi en participation citoyenne comme
nous venons d'ailleurs de le faire avec
la convention citoyenne sur la fin de
vie une réforme des institutions qui se
décident mais Emmanuel Macron ne parle
plus de la fameuse commission
transpartizane qui devait regrouper
toutes les forces politiques y compris
les oppositions pour dessiner cette
réforme des institutions en revanche le
président de la République c'est montrer
ouvert à travailler dans la suite de son
quinquennat avec tous ceux qui le
souhaitent écouter de celui-ci toutes
les forces d'action et de bonnes volonté
nos mères nos élus nos forces politiques
nos syndicats tous ensemble je compte
mieux les associer en relançant dès le
mois de mai des coalitions et alliances
nouvelles sur les bases solides du
Conseil national de la refondation au
plus près du terrain et chacun d'entre
vous avait un rôle à jouer avoir
maintenant ces manuel Macron va réussir
à rassembler autour de son action ce
n'est pas gagné quand on connaît sa
relation avec les oppositions en tout
cas le président veut utiliser ces 100
jours aussi pour restaurer l'unité du
pays Loic Hervé on l'a vu dans le
président de la République va travailler
sur des grandes pistes pour réformer nos
institutions selon vous quelles mesures
doivent être prises pour réformer notre
système démocratique a pour moi c'est
des mesures qui tiennent à l'exécutif et
à la manière dont l'exécutif fonctionne
le couple président de la République
première ministre et le gouvernement
notamment gouvernement dans sa relation
avec le Parlement je m'explique
aujourd'hui président de la République
est dans une posture non reliée des
choses c'est à dire qu'il est très
impliqué dans les affaires intérieures
la première ministre en fait exécute
elle défendent secrétaire général de
l'Élysée super secrétaire général de
l'isée et le gouvernement est
pléthorique avec des ministres inconnus
dans un certain nombre
font des choses dont que le Parlement
ignore c'est à dire que on sait pas trop
ce que telle ou tel secrétaire d'État au
ministre délégué fabrique donc il faut
un gouvernement resserré politique une
première ministre qui soit vraiment en
charge de de la gestion du pays ce que
la Constitution prévoit et un président
de la République qui prennent de la
distance et qui qui soit en capacité si
s'il l'appelle d'être justement
et d'aller chercher des des alliés pour
un gouvernement de mission pas pour pas
pour aller exécuter un programme qui est
forcément le programme que lui seul aura
décidé mais ça suppose non pas des mines
réformes constitutionnelles mais un
changement complet de manière d'être et
d'agir d'abord du premier d'entre nous
qui est le président de la République
veut-il lui-même abandonner une partie
de ces prérogative veut-il en confier
davantage à sa première ministre et
veut-il avoir des ministres politiques
qui travaillent avec le gouvernement de
manière intelligente moi il se trouve
qu'ici dans cette maison au Sénat je
travaille sur les questions de sécurité
intérieure et de sécurité civile donc
quand le détecte arrive à la commission
des lois avec d'autres collègues comme
marfield ovress nous travaillons par
exemple sur les questions de police de
gendarmerie de sur des questions
intérieures nous avons un ministre
référent qui est très politique qui
s'appelle Gérald Darmanin il y a aucun
problème
mais je plains mes collègues qui ont qui
travaillent dans d'autres domaines où
ils ont des référents au gouvernement
qui sont
des référents techniques jamais
politiques où il est très très difficile
d'avancer sur tel ou tel sujet parce que
le ministre est tenu par ses
collaborateurs sont cabinet ou n'osent
pas faire de la politique il faut dans
ce pays on arrive à faire de la
politique on est dans une situation de
minorité à l'Assemblée nationale de
majorité relative si l'on veut et donc
il faut juste accepter cette réalité là
et que le fonctionnement instituel du
pays vous savez la Cinquième République
est robuste mais il faut que le
fonctionnement du pays s'adapte à la
nouvelle réalité politique je suis pas
sûr qu'il faille aller modifier la
Constitution pour changer quoi que ce
soit
plus de ministres politiques comme
Gérald Darmanin faut moins de ministre
en général et il faut qu'on ait des
interlocuteurs et des jeux et des
personnes qui prennent les sujets à bras
le corps et qui les fasse avancer donc
pour vous faut être déprésidentialisé
finalement le régime
un centriste de de je suis un
parlementariste militant et je pense que
sans sans avoir le risque de de retomber
sous la Quatrième République il faut
qu'on ait une capacité d'assumer que
nous sommes une démocratie parlementaire
et que nous fassions confiance au
Parlement assemblée et Sénat et que nous
fassions confiance au corps
intermédiaire c'est juste que l'exécutif
se rendre compte qu'en face de lui il y
a le pays réel hier il a appelé à
relancer les coalitions les alliances
solides est-ce que vous pourriez
participer à ça alors la participation
d'un certain nombre de formations
politiques
qui concourent d'ailleurs à l'exercice
démocratie dans la Constitution à un
gouvernement
nommé par Emmanuel Macron supposerait
qu'on a un gouvernement de mission
c'est-à-dire que pour une durée donnée
il y est des
impacts de gouvernement précis durée de
nez qui n'est pas forcément d'ailleurs
le terme du mandat présidentiel mais qui
qui serait de dire que et d'ailleurs
c'est ce que Emmanuel Macron aurait dû
faire après les législatives c'est à
dire que à l'allemande de dire nous
avons un certain nombre de choses à
faire dans l'intérêt du pays
il y avait retraites on voit bien
comment ça ça se finit il y a les sujets
d'immigration qui sont dessus important
il y a les sujets travail pouvoir
d'achat et dans cette durée là de dire
voilà voilà le programme voilà le
programme que je propose et sur cette
base là construite d'ailleurs ou pas
avec un syndrome de formation politique
qui ne sont pas aujourd'hui dans la
majorité on va il est encore temps pour
vous
ce que j'ai entendu hier soir à part des
incantations et je vous avais dit une
forme d'enfilage de perles c'est pas le
chemin qu'on prend mais c'est le sens du
Labin la droite et au centre hier c'est
le seul moyen de faire avancer le pays
le veut-il vraiment et vous
moi je crois que c'est le seul moyen si
on veut pas moi moi si vous voulez ma
seule inquiétude c'est que aux
prochaines élections présidentielles on
n'est pas un président de la République
qui viennent de la France insoumise ou
de rassemblement national c'est le seul
sujet qui m'a en fait qui me qui me
préoccupe qui m'empêche vraiment de
dormir parce que je pense qu'on on prend
vraiment le chemin de cela entre Pif
Gadget Playboy et le bras d'honneur du
ministre de la Justice à un
parlementaire dans la séquence qu'à
aucun moment on ait eu une remise en
ligne du gouvernement en disant que
maintenant il s'agirait de en gros de
siffler la fin de la récré et que les
ministres notamment un certain nombre
d'entre eux se mettent vraiment à avoir
des attitudes acceptables dans la
période de gravité qui est dans notre on
n'est pas des seins
ça j'en suis bien conscient on est des
êtres humains hommes et femmes
parlementaire ministre etc mais il faut
un peu de décence quand même
alors la première ministre Isabelle
borne est maintenue au moins jusqu'au 14
juillet au terme de ces 100 jours est-ce
que ça peut être la bonne chef de
gouvernement de ce gouvernement de
mission politique que vous souhaitez
il faudra que Elizabeth borne est
davantage d'empathie et de capacité à
trouver des dialogues je l'ai rencontré
pour un certain nombre de fois c'est une
femme que j'estime honnête
travailleuse pleine de bonnes volonté
mais il faut qu'elle fasse davantage de
de politique je reviens sur ce sujet là
encore une fois c'est une
elle vient autre fonction publique elle
a une dimension de technicienne elle
connaît très bien ses sujets mais il
faut qu'elle fasse de la politique et
faire de la politique ça suppose voilà à
un moment donné d'ouvrir aussi sa
personne de craquer un peu l'armure pour
vis-à-vis des Français et vis-à-vis des
des formations politiques d'être capable
aussi d'élargir le spectre vous savez la
majorité présidentielle elle s'est rendu
compte qu'elle était face à des
difficultés importantes avec les
dernières législatives
mais de de cette prise de conscience aux
actes il y a parfois encore du chemin
c'est vrai pour la première ministre
mais c'est vrai aussi pour certaines
attitudes à l'Assemblée nationale ou
parfois on a encore l'impression d'être
en 2017
dernière question sur cette méthode du
Conseil national de la refondation qui
est déclinée en plusieurs thématiques
Emmanuel Macron a estimé que c'était une
réussite et il voulait approfondir cette
méthode qu'est-ce que vous en pensez
vous tout arrêter faut tout arrêter faut
arrêter de faire croire
au peuple et assez représentants que il
y aurait une forme de de démocratie
spontanée qui viendrait du simple fait
que le Président de la République
appuierait sur un bouton qui s'appelle
CNR et que de ce conseil national la
refondation
on aurait employé en plus à un terme qui
qui fait qui nous rappelle 43 à 44
on aurait tout de suite des bonnes idées
qui émergeraient comme ça du pays par
une forme de spontanéité démocratique et
non c'est pas ça marche pas ça et donc
autant le CNR que les histoires
convention citoyenne du climat ou fin de
vie faut arrêter le plus vite possible
cette ce type de méthode là parce qu'en
fait c'est ce [__] de la figure du
Parlement et des corps intermédiaires et
du monde des locaux on a largement dans
le pays entre le Conseil économique et
social les associations d'élus le
Parlement on a largement de quoi faire à
nouveau créer de nouveaux bidules qui
servirait à en plus à servir la soupe à
l'exécutif parce que moi je peux vous
dire que les conclusions de la
Convention nationale sur la fin de vie
on aurait pu les écrire
voilà et quand on regarde comme outil
est intervenu devant cette convention
nationale y compris chez les philosophes
qui étaient tous favorables aux
utilisateurs assistés et à l'euthanasie
il y a un événement de quoi remettre en
cause complètement ce type là donc ce
type de méthode là je dis ouvrir la
République il faut arrêter tout ça et
pas dire sur les bases solides du CNR
ouais enfin tu pardon tu parles sur la
fin de vie le Parlement aurait
évidemment le dernier mot il y a un
projet de loi qui va être présenté mais
ça veut dire que vous le voterez
si
voter c'est voté les conclusions du CNR
jamais de la vie jamais de la vie moi je
suis pour le les soins palliatifs je
suis pour qu'on aille au bout de
l'application la loi cléonetti mais le
suicide assisté et le l'euthanasie dans
mon pays jamais et je me battrai sur ces
sujets là c'est des sujets qui renvoient
chez moi à aux raisons d'être de mon
engagement politique et
finalement à ce qu'est un être humain
à raison d'être de ce qu'est la personne
humaine et donc c'est pas c'est
certainement pas ces conclusions là que
je voterai j'ai beaucoup de choses à
dire sur ce sujet là
on en reparlera évidemment avec vous on
va remercier Alex d'abord à tout à
l'heure on se retrouve dans le club pour
parler des chantiers économiques que
veut lancer Emmanuel Macron ce sera dans
le club et on va voir l'actualité dans
votre région avec nos partenaires de la
presse régionale bonjour Frédéric Thiers
merci beaucoup d'être avec nous chef
d'agence du Dauphiné libération de
Maurienne on va parler dans tout au
sujet avec vous on va parler du lion
[Musique]
alors le lion Turin aujourd'hui sont
deux réalités ou plutôt une réalité le
tunnel en lui-même un tunnel de base en
pleine construction et puis une
virtualité sont les accès aux lions
Turin le tunnel un double tube deux fois
57 km entre Saint-Jean-de-Maurienne en
Savoie et Suze de l'autre côté des Alpes
plus des galeries annexes déjà creusé
environ 17% la livraison de l'ouvrage
c'est pour 2032 l'objectif c'est faire
passer dedans 40 millions de tonnes de
marchandises par an
ça a un coup bien sûr le tunnel c'est 8
milliards 6 euros et le financement
prévu au départ c'était l'Europe 40 %
l'Italie 35% la France 25% vous me direz
pourquoi l'Italie paie plus que la
France à l'origine Rome avait accepté
cette participation parce que un tunnel
neuf qui débouche de chaque côté sur un
réseau vieillissant ça ne sert à rien il
faut des accès à ce tunnel or entre
Turin et Suze il n'y a que quelques
dizaines de kilomètres de la plupart
c'est à plats les Italiens ont déjà
phasé et financés ses accès il nous
disent qu'ils sont livrés en même temps
que le tunnel en 2032 donc
en France c'est plus compliqué il faut
réaliser le contournement ferroviaire de
l'agglomération lyonnaise le fameux
CEFAL et aussi une ligne nouvelle entre
Lyon et Saint-Jean-de-Maurienne ça fait
140 km et une grande partie c'est en
Souter
les accès français ils ont été validés
par une déclaration d'utilité publique
en 2013 mais depuis bien il y a plus
rien aucune décision pas d'argent ni
dans le dossier rien du tout Laurent est
prête là encore financer jusqu'à la
moitié de ses accès et mais la France ne
lui a même rien demandé du tout du coup
l'Union s'impatiente et l'Italie aussi
l'Italie se demande si elle n'est pas en
train clairement se faire avoir par la
France qui lui a fait payer plus pour le
tunnel de base en échange d'accès
qu'elle ne fera jamais
du côté de l'Europe c'est pour l'avenir
du réseau ferroviaire continental qu'on
est inquiet le lion Turin en effet c'est
le maillon d'un corridor qui est bien
plus long qui va du sud de l'Espagne ou
Lisbonne jusqu'à Budapest et puis sans
doute plus tard jusqu'à Kiev et c'est
aussi un des très rares axes Est-Ouest
en Europe ou alors que tous les réseaux
européens sont aujourd'hui plutôt
orientés du Nord vers le Sud alors la
question qu'on a envie de vous poser le
hic Hervé c'est est-ce qu'il y a urgence
à faire avancer ce dossier ou alors
est-ce qu'on peut attendre encore un
petit peu comme le suggère le Conseil
des réorientation des infrastructures
qui verrait bien ses accès repoussés
2042 voir 2045
c'est une excellente question et bravo
pour ce résumer
extrêmement précis de ce qu'est le
projet Lyon Turin vous savez comme vous
j'imagine moi je vis dans une vallée
alpine qui s'appelle la vallée de l'Arve
et comme la vallée de la Maurienne par
exemple nous sommes confrontés depuis
des années au sujet de l'engorgement et
de la pollution de l'air
je le dis avec une certaine émotion et
aussi une certaine irritation quand on
parle de renvoyer les accès français à
2045 on tourne le dos à des engagements
français vis-à-vis l'Union européenne
qui touche à la vie quotidienne des
hauts savoyards et des savoyards et en
fait j'ai pas d'humour avec ce sujet là
et si nous sommes des dizaines et des
dizaines de parlementaires alors autour
d'Etienne Blanc la semaine dernière mais
aussi des parlementaires de la majorité
présidentielle qui ont qui sont montés
au créneau c'est que on veut simplement
qu'on arrête de nous prendre pour des
imbéciles et on veut simplement
du Nord la parole du pays de réaliser
les choses il y a 5 ans quand le
mouvement 5 étoiles en Italie remettait
en cause les accès du côté italien
j'avais posé une question d'actualité au
Gouvernement à Elisabeth borne qui était
ministre des Transports j'ai retrouvé
cette question et elle dit clairement
qu'il faut honorer la parole de l'Italie
vis-à-vis de l'Union européenne comme
d'ailleurs nous devons honorer la parole
de la France vis-à-vis de ce projet le
lion Turin il faut le faire le tube
principal est en cours moi je suis allé
sur le chantier c'est un projet
extraordinaire c'est un des grands
investissements imaginez qu'on ait fait
le tunnel sous la Manche sans faire
Londres Douvres ou Paris Calais ce
serait ridicule et ben c'est même sujet
en fait il faut faire les accès en même
temps que le tube principal est livré
l'intégralité de l'infrastructure l'État
doit être au rendez-vous un dernier mot
Frédéric
oui et selon vous justement le carré
qu'est ce que peuvent faire des
parlementaires de surcroît d'opposition
en d'autres termes ce que la voie l'élu
la voix du politique la force des
traités signés ont encore quelques poids
face à celui de l'administration ou au
moins de certaines administrations dont
au moins on sait qu'elle traîne des
pieds c'est moins qu'on puisse dire et
bien il faut rappeler
au Conseil d'orientation des
infrastructures qu'il n'est pas le
Parlement que c'est le Parlement qui
fait la loi dans ce pays et que
l'exécutif est en charge d'exécuter ces
cas de le dire les lois et les
engagements internationaux qui ont été
pris la force de ce projet c'est qu'il a
été soutenu par l'intégralité des
gouvernements au pouvoir dans notre pays
depuis une vingtaine d'années
qu'ils agissent de gouvernement de
gauche ou de gouvernement de droite donc
on a une une force c'est de de au-delà
de l'opposition parce que je suis vous
savez il y a Joël Giraud qui soutient
notre notre initiative donc on peut pas
dire que Joël soit dans l'opposition où
il y a des parlementaires comme moi qui
sont des parlementaires modérés et qui
n'avons jamais voulu faire de la
politique politicienne sur ces sujets là
et puis il y a des gens qui sont
beaucoup plus à gauche beaucoup plus à
droite que moi et qui souviennent donc
c'est une espèce de front commun que
nous faisons pour dire au gouvernement à
la première ministre et au ministre des
Transports nous devons réaliser ce
projet dans les temps il y a urgence
merci fré merci d'avoir été avec nous
100 jours pour se relancer c'est à la
une du Dauphiné aujourd'hui évidemment
ça parle de l'allocution d'évaluelles
Macron merci beaucoup d'avoir été avec
nous merci Loic Hervé d'avoir été notre
invité pendant cette première demi-heure
et à très vite évidemment dans cette
émission dans 20 minutes dans le club
des territoires on revient sur la
locution d'Emmanuel Macron des banques
entre deux économistes Jean-Marc Daniel
et Mathieu plage ce sera à suivre et on
en parle tout de suite avec notre
prochain invités